chuckle as an over-thinker you missed
some factors anxiety low confidence low
IQ or IQ perfectionism and often a
failure to prioritize yes so this is a
question from the last podcast and this
guy just sent me this tweet and I
thought it was a good assessment because
I'm not an over-thinker mm-hmm and maybe
this guy is and sorry I don't have his
Twitter callsign there but he may be
he's an over-thinker so he kind of knew
about it and if you don't remember the
question you know it's someone that
overthinks things they get analysis
paralysis right they just start thinking
and thinking and thinking they're frozen
from their own thoughts too many
thoughts and so I thought these were
good little factors here and it
basically up to me and all boils down to
actually fear mm-hmm because if you're
thinking then you're not taking action
and if you're not taking action then
there's no consequence and if there's no
consequence and there's nothing to be
afraid of so I think that the
overthinking can be an excuse for actual
fear and same thing with like I'm a
perfectionist that's also fear it's fear
of not being perfect and then on top of
that low confidence well if you have low
confidence guess what your afraid your
confidence is low you're not sure
yourself so you sit around and think
about doing it instead of actually doing
it and then anxiety well yeah anxiety
actually is fear you're afraid to do
something and then IQ now that might be
I guess maybe someone has a high IQ and
therefore they're thinking a lot and
maybe that's not fear but let me ask you
a question if you're so smart then why
aren't you taking action and making
something happen so you got a big IQ
that's no excuse to sit around and
overthink things especially because if
you're so smart why can't you come up
with a quick solution why can't you
realize that overthinking is actually
causing the problem harm it's not moving
the problem forward mmm-hmm so quit
thinking so much and take action